for those of you who don't remember
Lindsay you may have seen this clip
Lindsay on the clip take it away hello
my name is Lindsey Graham and I am a cat
meow meow I'm not a woman dressed as a
cat I am a cat by show of hands I'm
curious uh how many of you believe and
confess that I'm a cat
Great I Am by show of hands I'm curious
how many of you believe that your child
or a child from this school would
believe that I'm actually a cat no one
you are right why
because you are not stupid and these
children are not stupid
Lindsay
we are not stupid
you are not a cat we are very happy to
have you on the show thank you for
coming on
thank you so much I appreciate that my
little kids I have a three six and
nine-year-old they've started to
memorize that speech and they walk
around the house saying my name is
Lindsey Graham and I am a cat so I guess
I have to teach them about
transgenderism sooner than I thought
well you you better because you you said
your youngest is three yes well she's
ready to identify now he is well yeah
according according to pre-k public
pre-K in certain States your kid could
be taught about transgenderism already
what has the reaction been just in your
local community uh to your magnificent
speech in the cat costume which I would
thank you for wearing on the show today
you're very welcome I have it easily
accessible now
um it was really positive uh the man
that I was speaking out against which is
Paul Bixler he's 72 years old he's lived
a full life as a man married to a woman
two children all of a sudden he has what
I consider a mental breakdown and I was
told that he's wearing his wife's
clothing and he's now identifying as a
woman and having children call him Miss
Bixler he's done nothing to to Really
identify as a woman not that that
matters other than put on dresses and
the community has been outraged and
actually you know I'm sure you know this
a lot of people aren't paying attention
still and so that little charade of mine
the meow meow it got a lot of attention
um which I'm I'm fine with good and bad
but but a lot of people in the community
had no idea that this man even existed
and that he was attending all of the
elementary school functions spelling
bees carnivals using the little girls
restrooms by the way at these events so
it brought a lot of attention to the
school district in a good way more
people started showing up to the school
boards to email a lot of the two of the
board members are very conservative and
messaged me and said we are getting
flooded with emails parents didn't even
know that this man that he was doing
this what what grade does this guy teach
so he's on a school board of the
district which is oversees all of them
mm-hmm wow and by the way you know it
goes beyond he dresses as a woman and
makes kids call him Miss Bixler he's
advocated and voted for uh bills that
allow children to identify differently
at school and not inform the parents he
is
pro-transgenders in sports so he's your
typical liberal he wants gender to be
fluid and non-existent and for men to be
able to dominate girls in their
bathrooms and in sports wow this is even
worse than I had suspected for some
reason in my mind he was a teacher but
no so if he's on the board that means
that he's actually setting the policy
which if he were just a teacher for one
classroom of kids you'd say okay well
it's too bad for that classroom and it's
it's going to be really hard though to
to get rid of a teacher you know these
unions are so crazy now it's pretty much
impossible to fire them but no this is a
person who's playing a role crafting
policy in a in austensive self-governing
Democratic Republic and so if he's
crafting the policy then he's shaping
the whole education of all of the
students and don't parents have a right
to say no
they absolutely do but you know what I
want to tell you something Michael this
man went and got a harassment injunction
against me and he tried to serve me
repeatedly at my home in front of my
children and when that didn't work he
tried to serve me he did serve me at
this the next school board meeting
because he didn't want me speaking out
against him an elected official who
doesn't like the opposition speaking out
files a harassment injunction against me
and has a cop serve me publicly at the
school board
tells you everything that you need to
know again that would be outrageous
enough if he were a teacher because
you'd say well he's receiving a public
salary I'm paying your salary you're
teaching my kids I have some right to to
say what goes on in the classroom
this is an elected official this is a
politician this guy is so directly
accountable to you except what they want
to do is they want to take the power and
then crowd out all the parents you're
seeing this with all of the bills about
not only the curriculum but about the
books in elementary school libraries
around the country you're seeing the
Educators and the elected officials
saying the people the parents have no
right to determine what kind of books
their kids are being taught well then
what rights do we have I guess we have
no rights in education yeah exactly and
and if you do speak up you're you're
certainly going to get targeted by the
Liberals and all of their minions and
you know he his transition if you will
has become a massive distraction in the
district the school board has said so
the news has said so the parents have
said so the the school Educators have
said so and he has been asked to step
down simply because you know you're a
distraction and you're we're not able to
focus on the kids education while you're
sitting there in your pearl earrings
trying to be addressed as a and it's a
distraction and for that reason alone we
think you should recuse yourself he
refuses to do it yeah he refuses to do
it he he believes no I'm entitled to
behave and act and look and vote on
policies that I believe in whether or
not my community supports me or not the
community does not support him and you
know you were you were just talking
about liberals and their mentality and
how
um you're not if you're not qualified to
speak on something you shouldn't be
speaking on it well public slur is not a
woman so for him to walk around the
school and tell little kids to address
him as a woman he needs to step down I
think my favorite part about your entire
political campaign here is the obvious
provocation to the libs and as far as I
can tell they have taken the beta on
this which is yes Lindsay you're dressed
in a way that is inappropriate that it's
inappropriate for you to dress this way
at a school board meeting or whatever
and you say
go on tell me more about dressing
inappropriately wow what an interesting
topic I'd love to have that conversation
why don't I show up just as a drag queen
next and we'll see what you think about
that
yeah they um the there was a little bit
of hate and mind you the hate is is
minimal because if I were to stop and
waste my life arguing with liberals who
will never change their mind I would
dominate them easily but you can't
reason with them and so some of the
comments were your speech is ridiculous
obviously you can't be a cat and I'm
like
obviously men can't be women either yeah
but you're willing to have that argument
well the choice of the the cat Avatar I
don't know if this was intentional or
not but it's profound in that one of the
early national news stories about this
weird kind of identity dysphoria was
from I think it was about 20 years ago
there was this character I forget his
name but he went by stalking cat that
was his gnome to plume and he thought
that he was a cat and he had I think he
won the world record for all of the the
largest number of body modifications to
look like an animal and he really
mutilated himself it was very very sad
he ended up committing suicide obviously
the guy had had some problems he was
part of the furry community it turns out
and
he went down a sexually deviant Rabbit
Hole of delusional identity that did not
re down to his benefit or the benefit of
society at all and so when you show up
to the school board and you draw this
parallel with your cat costume that's
not out of left field that's not totally
crazy and absurd in fact there's recent
precedent for just such an analogy
exactly yeah and honestly the the cat
costume was literally laying around
because I had worn it for Halloween and
um I want to give a shout out to my
friend Kristen Newton She Loves You by
the way watches you all the time I wrote
my cat speech um because I needed it to
be
I'm kind of Hardcore I don't know if
you've noticed and she's like well let's
go in and edit and maybe take out some
of these raw emotions and put you know
real real facts into this so she helped
me edit my cat's cat speech she's an
incredible writer and it was just ironic
that I had a cat costume laying around
and and Michael this was the first
school board I'd ever spoken at ever in
my life really yeah see this is it went
viral it well yeah you clearly knocked
it out of the park great job to your
friend who edited the speech it really
came off very very well and it's it's
been one of the best examples of a broad
Nationwide phenomenon we're seeing which
is parents stepping up and speaking out
and I wonder if if this is catching on
right now
if this is such a winning issue for
conservatives in Virginia which is a
pretty blue Commonwealth in Florida in
all over the country if this is such a
winning issue because
people don't have a problem with liberal
leftist absurd policies in the abstract
oh the man wants to chop himself up okay
let him do it okay that's fine
they only start to have a problem with
it when it affects them and their school
districts and their kids and all of a
sudden pretty I was just with the moms
for Liberty the other night down here in
in Nashville and
you had people who were Democrats you
had people who were who voted left for a
lot of Their Lives who said wait what's
going on with my kids I don't think so
whatever they're for I'm against yep
well and and that's why it's okay to
take the hate that people call me of
course you can imagine a transphobic and
homophobic all the time and I said look
these are not the first drag queens to
exist and and they're certainly not the
first transgender people to exist you
notice that we have a problem when you
try to indoctrinate our kids with it and
that is the problem that I have and and
continue to have with Paul Bixler
sitting on the board if he wants to
dress like a woman in the privacy of his
own home well that is a problem for him
but when you bring it out into society
and you sit on a school board and you
dictate to little children to call you a
woman when they know because they're not
stupid that you're not a woman you
create a problem in society and you
expect everyone else to fix it for you
just like the transgenders in the
restrooms okay if you want to chop off
your penis and wear lipstick and pretend
that you can even remotely do what I can
do whatever have fun with that but you
can't come into my don't come into my
restroom and then demand writes that I
actually have yeah and and demand new
rights that exist for you because you've
created a problem for yourself you solve
it don't expect me and my kids to solve
this this is a nuanced take that the
libs don't understand that we understand
which is we're not saying that five
years ago was the first time ever that a
man wanted to pretend that he was a
woman no this phenomenon has been going
on for all of human history the
phenomenon of having sexually eccentric
kind of desires and perceptions you go
back and read Plato's Symposium and
Aristophanes in Plato's Symposium
describe soul mates as being some people
are a man and their soulmate is a woman
and they're two halves and they make a
whole and for some people it's two women
and for some people it's two men and
there are all these ideas have
percolated for a long time eunuchs a
transvestites these ideas and these kind
of eccentricities they've been around
for a long time the thing that's new
is that we're pretending that it's
normal the thing that's new yes is that
we're pretending that this is conducive
to human flourishing the thing that's
new is we're pretending that it's true
that you know that a man can actually
become a woman that is what is so absurd
as you say some guy wants to put on his
his wife's blouse in his own closet
we're not sending the morality police
door to door to make sure that he's
wearing overalls or blue jeans but right
when you come into the Public Square you
have a responsibility to observe the
standards and norms and rules and laws
of the political community and it's not
just the crazy lips who get to make
those rules it's ordinary people it's
citizens it's parents parents like you
even parents who put on a cat suit to
make a point Lindsay where can people
find you
my website is patreonbarby.com I am most
active on Instagram which is
the.patriot.barby
Patriot barbie.com go follow Lindsay no
Lindsay I hope you go enjoy a nice bowl
of milk and I hope that you get
everything that you're after in your
political campaign because you were
totally on the right track thank you for
coming on thank you
foreign